hey everyone so in the last video i was
talking about divergence and kind of
laying down the intuition that we need
for it where you're imagining a vector
field is representing some kind of fluid
flow where particles move according to
the vector that they're attached to in
that point in time and as as they move
to a different point the vector they're
attached to is different so their their
velocity changes in some way and the key
question that we want to think about is
if you have a given point somewhere in
space does fluid tend to flow towards
that point or does it tend to flow more
away from it does it diverge away from
that point
and what i want to do here is start kind
of closing our grasp on that intuition a
little bit more tightly as if we are
trying to discover the formula for
divergence ourselves because ultimately
that's that's what i'm going to get to a
formula for divergence but i want it to
be something that's not just plopped
down in front of you but something that
you actually you know feel deep in your
bones so a vector field like the one i
have pictured above is given as a
function a multi-variable function with
a two-dimensional input since it's a
two-dimensional vector field and then
some kind of two-dimensional output and
it's common to
write p and q as the functions for these
the components of the output so p and q
are each just scalar valued functions
and you think of them as the components
of your vector-valued output and the
divergence
is kind of like a derivative where it's
you might denote it by just div and in
the same way that your derivative you
have this operator and what it does is
it takes in a function and what you get
is a whole new function this div
operator you think of as taking in a
vector field of some kind and you get a
new function and the new function you
get will be scalar valued it'll be
something that just takes in points in
space and outputs a number
because what you're thinking the thing
that it's trying to do is take in some
specific point with x y coordinates and
just give you a single number to tell
you hey does fluid tend to diverge away
from it how much or does it tend to flow
towards it and how much
so this is this is the kind of the form
of the thing that we're going for
so here what we're going to do is just
start thinking about
cases where this divergence is positive
or negative or zero and what that should
look like so for example
let's say we want cases where the
divergence of our vector field at a
specific point at a specific point x y
is positive
what might that look like
so one case would be where your point
nothing is happening at that point the
vector attached to it is zero and
everyone around it is going away this is
kind of the extreme example of positive
divergence
and i animated this in the last video
where we have um you know all of the
vectors pointing away from the origin
and if you look at a region around that
origin all the fluid particles kind of
go out of that region and that's
that's the quintessential positive
divergence example but it doesn't have
to look like that it actually i mean you
could have something where there is a
little bit of movement at your point um
and then maybe there's movement towards
it as well from one side and vectors are
kind of going towards it but they're
going away from it even more rapidly
uh on the other side so if you think of
any kind of actual region around your
point you're saying sure fluid is going
into that region a little bit but it's
much more counterbalanced by how quickly
it's going out
so these are these are the kind of
situations you might see for positive
divergence now negative divergence
negative divergence let's think about
what examples of that might look like
divergence of v
at a given point
and you know really it's something that
takes in all points of the plane but
we're just looking at specific points
so if the divergence is negative
well the quintessential example here is
that nothing happens at your point but
all of the vectors around it are kind of
flowing in towards it and this is the
thing where i animated where we took
this and we flipped all of the vectors
and said ah there if you start playing
the fluid flow then the density in any
region around the origin you know
increases a lot all of the fluid
particles tend to converge towards that
center
but again this isn't the only example
that you might have you could have a
little bit of activity at your point
itself and maybe it is the case that
things do flow away from it a little bit
as you're going away and some of the
fluid particles are going away and it's
just the case that the fluid particles
flowing in towards it from another
direction heavily counterbalance that
because then if you're looking at any
kind of region around your point you say
fluid particles are coming in quite
rapidly a lot of particles per time but
they're not leaving too rapidly around
the other end so kind of loosely
intuitively this is this is what a
negative divergence case might look like
and finally another case that we want to
start thinking about as we're tightening
our grasp on this intuition is what
happens or what does it look like if the
divergence of your function at a
specific point
is zero
right if it's just absolutely zero
and one thing this could look like is
you know you have something going on but
nothing really changes and all of the
the fluid just kind of flows in and it
flows out and on the whole it's um
it balances you know if you take any
kind of region the amount flowing in is
balanced with the amount flowing out but
it could also look like you have fluid
flowing in
kind of from one dimension but it's
cancelled out by flowing away from the
point
in a manner that sort of perfectly
balances it in another direction so
these are the loose pictures that i want
you to have in the back of your mind as
as we start looking for the actual
formula for divergence and what i'll do
in the next video or two is start
looking at these functions p and q and
thinking about the partial derivative
properties that they have that will
correspond with you know this these
positive divergence images that you
should have in your head or the negative
divergence images that you should have
in your head so with that i'll see you
next video